[Music]
good warn you guys I will say some
horrific [__] up here but it's all jokes
we're all gonna die one day just yuck em
ups don't Will Smith me you know
still can't believe that [__] happened
Chris Rock's a goddamn Pro for him
that's so well you know yeah I got
called a homo once in a college gig I
almost slit my wrist
for him
I will say I'm just glad Chris Rock
didn't make a joke by Alec Baldwin's
wife
comes back like you know he's coming
back he's got a Slave movie coming out
you know which it's kind of appropriate
for him because he's used to the
backlash but uh yeah
I'm married to Jada pink
ett hey all right all right we're
getting there the old ball and chain
okay in trouble at a comedy show
recently uh as I used a racial slur but
I didn't even know it was a slur right
no idea but in my defense can we all
agree that the gentlest of the racial
slurs has got to be
I mean come on he's from China he's a
man not so bad
to me the names of Chinese restaurants
actually sound a lot more like racial
slurs
let's try something
you know who can't drive
those freaking Panda cakes
they cannot drive at all listen to this
one of those golden noodles is one of my
apartment building
we've been right next door to me they're
one big happy family
all right I can do that joke
the Black Snow White
and Seven little white dwarfs no they
gotta be black doors that's funnier like
we got a sassy
[Music]
I wish I wish you would I wish you would
you guys already told it to the shorty
black acidic Jews is that you sir
yes sir whoa get him
black acidic views holy [__] that's a
crazy combo huh have the curliest hair
on the planet holy hell
black acidic Jews what did you Yama go
off to the side you know
I bet that guy can spin adrenal faster
than any other uh heave out there I'll
tell you that wow they must have really
cut off a lot of foreskin on that dick
I'll tell you that
it's an athlete and your own sports
agent
what's your name sir
I was hoping for something fun you know
like uh arsidio Weinstein or some [__]
hello yes exactly
hey hey all right comedy huh we're
really doing it all right here we are in
Katz's right in the height of
anti-Semitism hey very exciting huh all
right the weird one for me is Kyrie
Irving because you know he supposedly
hates the Jews but I'm like if you hate
the Jews maybe don't play for Brooklyn
[Music]
a lot of Jews out there in the old BK
you know look if I hated kids I wouldn't
go to Nick Cannon's house you know
all right
comedy I love the Jews Bigfoot Jewish
women number one beautiful oh yeah oh
yeah man I met a girl in that Jewish app
what's that Jewish app uh PayPal yeah
all right we're having fun hey
cool
one to the left there the one from the
left that you're getting that's a lot of
gas wow that's a lot of gas in there and
uh wow that'll kill a Jew hey good uh
and uh
liked that one uh gas chamber [__] I
get you
first time well you know I don't like to
talk about your mom but uh
hey look who woke up
all right good to have you back you
[__] idiot
to go hey who knew all right white pants
bad for spotting all right
um
that's the first date oh all right well
glad you guys decided to come here and
chit chat
[Music]
biracial relationships well the porn is
great uh
I don't know about the relationship it
is oh boy I'm glad you're dating her not
me but um holy [__] it's nice to know
you guys are I thought you were mail
order so uh you know
sorry I'm just getting uh getting my
revenge you guys were a horrible table
all night
[Music]
okay
uh I'm not that cute
oh geez now you're getting free
all right well
that joke's ruined every Jump's like a
boner once I get yelled at by a lady
it's gone I never realize no
no we're not a serial killer
the staff went home
we should just pick her out I completely
agree but that's apparently up in the
club we're all the same color on the
inside
[Music]
keep it going down
[Applause]
I think they're gonna put it for sale
is that a blue over there what was that
what's that
we love you mark wait what did I do
wow
supporting prostitution yes I've given
them money for years
[Applause]
so crazy you think you're the good guy
in the movie you know
what a [__] [__] all right um oh is
that her oh great all right wait what
did I do where are you mad
start again what do you mean I'm
promoting it I'm telling a joke you
[__] psycho Jesus Christ
I don't think she's smart
suck my dick all right well
that's sexual assault you're promoted
suck my dick I'm sure that was
transphobic in some way if I really uh
we're really doing the numbers here ah
should have never [__] her yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody's talking about this guy I
don't care what should I know about this
guy is he good or bad
oh you enjoy it you like him no oh okay
I thought women handed him
are you gonna get your [__] she's fun
lady she does anal
she knows all right all right
yes
I want to smell that guy's hand
[Music]